step step in step dance doesn't look
like something I'd be very good at going
up I know it's a lot of this this is the
RISM ocarina we have five days to learn
how to step dance before we need to
perform in front of thousands of people
I am a little overwhelmed
stepping comes from African dances from
the root incorporated and tapping tap
dancing and things like that it has a
rich African tradition seeing say three
white dudes yeah an Asian guy yeah
stepping with you guys in unison I think
it's cool I think it says a lot in terms
of the way that the cultures transcended
the first thing about step is you're
going to be doing with mix and claps and
stomps you want to make those stomps as
loud as possible to make sure that we
catch the audience attention
I could do this all day there's no music
though you are the music easy enough
makes sense let's talk about this
performance we're doing it's at the USC
basketball gala Center using finale wait
no wait no it's not how many people are
gonna be there
ten thousand ten thousand people expect
it to be packed the entire success of
the movement is totally based on how
well everyone is doing together like all
the things I'm bad with us hang up in
any way tarnish your reputation that one
up we have the utmost confidence in you
guys well you just met us yeah I think
my problem is
do I look super Asian doing that I am
here serving some tea intellectually I
get it but hey Knight I'm not doing it
it is a lot of things to keep track into
your head all at once in there actually
good slowly but surely with it baby man
this isn't our first rodeo but we're not
good at rodeo the one thing that I
really love about stuff it is this
spirit when does the intense space come
into play black Greek letter
organizations were started in the early
1900's as eternities and sororities for
minorities in communities not welcome to
join predominately white fraternities of
time not only did they create their own
organizations that created an entire
identity within the organization
stepping is really just like a bonding
experience Greek life is not reclined
without stepping so you just like you
throw temperature okay you wanna cookie
there we go
and what you have like a group of people
in unison doing it that's something very
possible I'm just one guy but together
we're a team that one one more time oh
that's not it
one thing you should take from this
experience is community and like you
step you give off each others energy are
we your best three white and one Asian
student ever Oh
mos def gonna remain ignorant about a
culture if you don't step out of your
box to learn about it if we succeed we
will we will talk about the face all
braces I was like no Ned
pretty buff we're here it's the night of
the show whoa yeah I think our biggest
priority is making sure that we make the
fraternity proud tonight we spent about
eight hours now practicing between
Thursday and now we only have one time
to nail this so it's do or die it is do
or die
you only got one shot do not miss your
chance to drop whoa whoa who would want
to blow this opportunity only comes once
in a lifetime
what
yeah
you know I was actually really impressed
with the try guys you know they they
came in with no knowledge not even about
the pass themselves but about stepping
also and for them to come in and to
learn this in the week and be able to
perform upon all those people I mean it
was amazing like they really gave 110%
the unity was there the bible's they
were spirit there was this like amazing
spirit these guys are not only involved
in this great frat but they're focused
on education they're focused on
community and I really felt that working
with them our main goal is to get into
college and to graduate
serve the community and bring down
charging people and uplift bring abet we
need to do another one
I'm a human biology major pre-med and
I'm a business administration major
emphasis in finance we show our butts on
the Internet so